bill is a political scientist and he's
uniquely well positioned to talk about
how to advocate for children in a way
that's effective but I i would also i
want i would also mention that he does
also do research on the substantive
issues that he's going to be talking
about and in particular he's
particularly well known for the research
he's been doing lately on
pre-kindergarten programs so for those
of you who watched the State of the
Union last week you know the President
Obama made kind of an astounding
announcement about universal pre-k and a
lot of the foundation for that work is
work that's been done in tulsa oklahoma
which has been led by by bill Gormley so
i don't know if he'll talk about it
today but i hope you will at least
mention it because it's really fabulous
work so thank you for coming we look
forward to your talk Thank You Jane
thanks very much I'm happy to be here I
actually seldom visit Columbia
University but I do have one sentimental
attachment as it turns out this is where
my my maternal grandfather went to
school and his name was John furia that
was his anglicized name he was an
Italian immigrant and he matriculated at
Columbia University and his father who
didn't speak a word of English was very
very excited that his son was actually
going to get a college degree from
Columbia and so as his senior year
approached he kept bragging to his
friends at Italian of course that his
son Giovanni was going to get a ba
degree from Columbia University which
was great except that my grandfather was
majoring in physics so my grandfather
tried to explain to his father that a BS
degree was just as good if not better
than a ba degree but somehow that didn't
sink in and so being a very dutiful son
my grandfather went to see the Dean at
Columbia and convinced him that he
should get a ba degree even though he
was majoring in physics
so I hope you still have Dean's like
that here at Columbia Dean's with a
heart so I'm happy to talk today about
my new book which is called voices for
children as published by the Brookings
Institution and the book begins with a
paradox which is that children are
beloved in our society but our public
policies do not reflect that our public
policies do not reflect that if you look
at the extent of child poverty in the
United States 22% twice as high as the
poverty rate for seniors our policies do
not reflect that if you look at our
spending levels so the government
federal government at any rate spends
seven times as much on senior citizens
as it does on children if you look at a
wide range of public policies and public
policy outcomes you see that in many
respects children are not faring that
well in the United States of America and
in fact if you want to read more about
this you could read any of Jane Walt
Vogel's excellent books in which she she
talks very eloquently about that and
puts us children in comparative cross
national perspective on the other hand
we like kids right and we claim that we
care about them in addition to just
liking them and of course there have
been societal trends that have taken
place over the years that suggest that
in many ways we are at least be coming
in some respects a more child-friendly
society look for example at the
increasing role of fathers in child
rearing look at how fathers are spending
more time more quality time with their
children and assisting more vigorously
and more equally in the process of child
rearing on the other hand we have this
paradox and I think the reason for the
paradox is multifold for one thing we
know that children cannot vote and
that's really a big handicap because
they cannot
Lee advance their own cause as a result
they need surrogates they need other
people who will speak out on their
behalf because they really can't do it
themselves another challenge that helps
to explain this paradox is that children
are not uniquely loved in our society if
you if you do a public opinion survey
you find that ordinary Americans do in
fact think positively about children
they have warm and fuzzy feelings about
children but they also think positively
about some other groups they think
positively about the disabled they think
positively about senior citizens and so
yes children are loved but other groups
in our society are also loved another
challenge of course is the fact that we
have a very complex Madisonian political
system that was contrived to make it
really really difficult to get things
done and they've succeeded with a
vengeance so that's a challenge we not
only have checks and balances built into
the federal government but we have an
authentically federal system which under
the Tenth Amendment and other provisions
of the Constitution ensures that state
governments have a lot of discretion
which is sometimes good for children but
sometimes bad for children the mass
media's coverage of children's issues
has its its virtues but also its flaws
one of the problems that shantou angaar
has identified with mass media coverage
generally is a tendency to be episodic
rather than theme attic and its coverage
and if you look at coverage of
children's issues or coverage of
children generally in the mass media
you'll see ample evidence of that
because you're more likely to find a
story a human interest story or a
feature about a particularly lovable
child or
a pitiful child or a child facing some
unusual circumstances then you are to
find a story that connects lots of
children to bigger social and political
practices and policies in the wider
society and that makes it difficult for
us as a society to galvanize around
children as a cause except when
something really dramatic and really
exceptionally awful happens as in the
case of of the Newtown massacre another
factor that helps to explain this
children's paradoxes i've called it is
the absence of strong crowchild
institutions in the United States and by
that I mean that we don't have the kinds
of governmental organizations in
particular that could play a very
proactive role in supporting children
through public policy to give you one
example we have in all 50 states
Ombudsman for nursing home residents but
where are the Ombudsman for children
where are the Ombudsman for children and
child care where the Ombudsman for
children who can't get child care so
there is an absence of the kinds of pro
child institutions which arguably could
help us to make ours truly a more
child-friendly society so all these
arguments have some merit and so what
I've tried to do in this book is to
suggest that maybe there is another
argument that we ought to think about
which is that perhaps part of the
problem is the quality of the rhetoric
that we use on behalf of children in
support of children and in support of
particular children's programs maybe if
our policy arguments in support of
children's programs were a little bit
sharper pitched a little differently
packaged a little differently then maybe
we might be a
to have more positive effects on
children's public policies may be
advocates could do a better job of
securing mass media attention if they
were to rethink the way they frame
children's issues if they were to be as
clever for example as the folks who
decided to call the estate tax a death
tax and with that one phrase they
conjured up images which though they
didn't necessarily correspond to the
underlying reality proved to be
overwhelmingly persuasive and had
dramatic public policy impacts that
we're still living with today so the
premise of by book end of this talk
really is that some issue frames are
more effective than others the question
is which ones and for which voters and
for which politicians so there's an
interesting body of literature about
issue framing that you can find and I'm
pleased to say that it's it's a
multidisciplinary literature it's not
uniquely the province of political
science or psychology or sociology it's
really a genuinely multidisciplinary
literature and the literature attests to
the power of words the literature
attests to the fact that how we frame an
issue how we structure an argument has
an effect on people's perceptions and on
their convictions so I'm not going to
review this literature in any detail but
but just to give you an example there
have been some empirical studies by
political scientists in laboratory
situations using randomized experiments
where they've exposed students the
favourite guinea pigs of all
psychologists and political scientists
who do experimental research to some
different issue frames in conjunction
with a particular policy event
or a particular social event so one
example it comes to mind was the
decision by the Nazis to march on Skokie
Illinois which they knew would would be
inflammatory which they knew would be
extremely painful to residents of Skokie
whose parents or grandparents had
actually perished in the Holocaust so
they took this news event or this social
event and they packaged it in different
ways in one instance they packaged it as
a law and order issue in the other
instance they packaged it as a civil
liberties issue and lo and behold people
reacted very differently to the same
news story depending on how the issue
had been framed so there are lots of
other examples of this but the bottom
line is that when we decide to to focus
on one aspect of an issue as opposed to
some other aspect of an issue that
apparently innocent decision that we
often make in just an instant turns out
to be profoundly important in terms of
shaping people's opinions so there's
also literature that shows that
different kinds of people react
differently to different issue frames
I'm not going to summarize that
literature and I'll actually have more
to say about that in the talk and
there's a very interesting body of
literature that emphasizes the intimate
connection between issue framing and
moral arguments every time you frame an
issue you are implicitly making some
kind of moral statement there's a value
that either explicitly or implicitly
undergirds what you're saying and some
values as it turns out are more likely
to change public opinion than others so
being more cognitive
and more aware of these values can be an
important first step as you try to frame
these issues a little differently there
is an interesting moral psychologist
Jonathan height who has recently
migrated from the University of Virginia
up to New York City he's now teaching at
New York University and he's done an
excellent job of showing that liberals
and conservatives have very different
values and that may not come as a
revelation to most of you because if if
you listen to fox news you can easily
find what some of those values are if
you listen to some other networks you
could easily find what some alternative
values are let's say MSNBC for example
on the other hand what may come as news
to you is Heights rather surprising
finding that in some respects
conservatives have a more
multi-dimensional value system than
liberals do when he has probed
conservative values and contrasted them
to liberal values in a number of
societies not just our own he has
consistently reached the conclusion that
whereas liberals tend to value fairness
and caring conservatives tend to value
ferent fairness and caring and other
things too like authority and loyalty
for example and sanctity so it I
mentioned this in particular because if
if your value system roughly coincides
with one of those two modal groups and
you want to try to influence people who
roughly speaking represent one of those
other modal groups you probably want to
know a little bit more about their value
system and sometimes the more you learn
about other people's values the more
surprised you are so I think professor
Heights work is very instructive on that
turning now to my own work what I've
tried to do is to highlight some
different issue frames that we can use
for thinking about children and public
policy and indeed I focused for the most
part on some issue frames that have
already been widely used there are four
of them in particular that I highlight
in my book the first is what i call the
helping hand metaphor which should be
familiar to all of you love your
neighbor as yourself is one version of
the helping hand metaphor the second the
Equal Opportunity metaphor should also
be a very familiar to you everyone
deserves an equal chance in life this is
what the American Dream is supposedly
all about that's another very powerful
metaphor at least in theory the
prevention metaphor is sometimes used by
children's advocates the notion that
prevention is tree / is cheaper than
treatment the notion that it's it's
wiser to spend money on early childhood
education for example than it is to
spend money on juvenile courts and and
prisons later on an investment metaphor
has also attracted some attention in
recent years the notion that learning
baguettes learning that skill begets
skill the notion that if we invest in
children when they're young enough for
the investment to make a difference then
we as society will reap great rewards
down the road in the future so what I've
done here is to develop these arguments
a little bit just to remind you that we
have lots of different versions of
policy arguments in many policy debates
sometimes you have fairly full
statements of a policy argument
times you have an intermediate version
sometimes you have a truncated version
that simply fits on a bumper sticker
notice that there are also other more
extensive versions that I haven't even
put up here not simply because there
wasn't enough space but more importantly
because public officials in particular
are unlikely to look directly at those
kinds of documents and so the truth of
the matter is that a lot of these issue
frames take the form of a truncated
policy argument that could fit on a
bumper sticker and so that is yet
another reason why we need to think very
very carefully about the words we use
when we're discussing children's
programs become because sometimes the
only words that other people are going
to hear rightly or wrongly are the sound
bites that are extremely condensed
versions of more subtle and more
thoughtful arguments in other words you
have to choose your issue frame very
carefully but you also have to choose
your sound like very carefully so how
have children's issue frames look like
in recent years I begin with the 1960s
this is an issue frame that you found at
the White House Conference on children
and youth in 1960 where President
Eisenhower's secretary of what was then
the Department of Health Education and
Welfare or hgw said I find myself
thinking of a spiritual law of life thou
shalt love thy neighbor as thyself that
to him was an idea that should animate
this conference on children from my
vantage point this is a moralistic theme
or a moralistic frame another moralistic
frame could be found in the writings of
Michael Harrington on poverty in which
he argued that the moral obligation is
planed there must be a crusade against
this poverty in our midst Martin Luther
King Lyndon Johnson also used
moralistic frames frames like equal
opportunity frames like the helping hand
frame so if you look at the 1960s you
see that children's advocates often
invoked moralistic issue frames that
seemed to fit the temper of the times
now let's move forward in time through a
time capsule to the 2000s and look at
how the world has changed since Austin
Powers has has migrated to another
decade and in fact to another century
this is a wonderful quote I think from
John Dingell John Dingell said in the
Truman administration my father
introduced a universal health insurance
bill for humanitarian reasons today I
introduced it for economic reasons ok
big change in in the way that that the
Dingle family has packaged the same kind
of legislation over the years here's
another quote from education policy from
Dan goldhaber and Jane hanaway improving
the performance of the teacher workforce
is no longer just a moral imperative it
is also an economic imperative here we
have the famous heckman curve and a
quote from professor jim heckman of the
university of chicago it gets harder and
harder to remediate as we get older and
older the earlier the intervention the
higher the economic rate of return
therefore we should intervene early
rather than late for economic reasons
not for moral reasons and finally closer
to home here at Columbia University
Geoffrey Canada from the Harlem
Children's Zone for no more money than
we're spending on incarceration we can
ensure that our children graduate from
high school go to college and get
college degrees come back to their
neighborhoods prepared to be
productive citizens so Canada is also
making an economic argument in support
of early childhood education and also K
through 12 education so I don't want you
to simply take my word for it that
there's been a sea change over time if
you look at this chart which focuses on
congressional testimony by executive
branch officials from three Democratic
administrations you will see a shift
over time from moralistic issue frames
towards economic issue frames in all
three of these issue areas involving
poverty and social services education
and also child health the shift has been
more dramatic in some instances less
dramatic and other instances and you
might actually see somewhat different
shifts under Republican administrations
that could be for someone else to study
but I think what this signifies is that
perhaps without our fully noticing it
there has been a change in the kind of
public rhetoric that public officials
employ when discussing children's issues
here I focused on the rhetoric of one
very prominent children's advocate
marian wright edelman the head of the
Children's Defense Fund who's been a
leading advocate for children for the
past four decades and this shows you
based on a Content analysis of her
congressional testimony how her frames
have changed over time at the very
beginning with her very first
congressional testimony in the early
1970s you can see a very stark
difference with with ms Edelman
emphasizing moralistic frames virtually
to the exclusion of economic frames
over time however that has changed and
changed dramatically so if you look
roughly speaking at the present time you
will see that ms Adelman speeches in her
testimony to Congress are typically as
economic as they are moralistic in other
words it's about 5050 today as I
understand it mrs. Adelman was actually
the daughter of a preacher and so you
still see the a lot of evidence of that
in her speeches in her sense of moral
outrage on the other hand you also see
that she has pretty conspicuously
changed the issue frames that she
employs on behalf of children in her
public appearances at least in her
appearances before Congress is entirely
possible that she would use somewhat
different issue frames when she's
talking for example to to the staff or
when she's talking with some of the
Children's Defense Fund supporters out
in the hinterlands okay let me turn to
some empirical research I've done that
is aimed at at at answering what I see
is a very important question for people
who care about children public policy
and that is which of these issue frames
is more persuasive and so my first foray
into this area was a randomized
experiment that I conducted at
Georgetown University where I had a
captive audience and they couldn't
escape they were students in a freshman
political science course in American
government and their their mean old
nasty professors insisted that they take
this little survey that I administered
that took no more than five minutes so
it wasn't that painful for them
basically the question that I had them
focus on was whether a state government
should adopt a nurse Family Partnership
Program that provides home visits to
poor first-time mothers from pregnancy
who the
miles second birthday this hypothetical
question is based on an actual program
that some of you may have heard about
the nurse Family Partnership Program
which originated with dr. David olds and
which is going strong in many states
throughout the United States today so
what I did with this particular study
was to contrive an imaginary newspaper
article that looked like the real thing
and in in fact what I did was to create
four different versions of this
newspaper article and each of the
students in the introductory courses at
Georgetown received one of these
versions so they read one article per
student and this will give you a clearer
sense of what those articles look like
the first of these articles essentially
made it described the debate that was
supposedly going on in the Pennsylvania
State Legislature on this issue and it
essentially offered just a negative
argument namely that this particular
program the well-intentioned was too
costly the taxpayers we just can't
afford it we'd all like to be Santa
Claus but we can't we just can't do that
because of our financial circumstances
the second version of the same article
was was different it retained that
negative argument as did the others but
it added a new one a moralistic argument
which as it turns out was the helping
hand argument so I had a state
legislator make a helping hand argument
in an effort to counter the negative
argument which is that the program was
too costly the third version of the
article used an economic argument and
specifically an investment argument with
no helping hand argument and the final
version of the article used an economic
argument with a little evidence so the
state legislature not only said that the
nurse Family Partnership Program was a
good investment
in the future but also said specifically
that the benefit cost ratio was 321 so I
wanted to see which of these newspaper
articles was more persuasive than others
and this is just a fuller version of
those arguments I asked the students to
indicate using a Likert scale whether
they agreed or disagreed that the
Pennsylvania State Legislature should
create this nurse Family Partnership
Program if they strongly agreed they
assigned this a seven if they strongly
disagreed they assigned it a one and
there were intermediate options too so
this this gives you some sense of what
the what the response to the different
newspaper articles was in a nutshell
what this shows is that the economic
arguments were generally more persuasive
the economic arguments were more
persuasive to students than the
moralistic argument and either of those
arguments was more persuasive than no
positive argument at all so the point is
is not that the that a moralistic
argument is a waste of time or breath
but that at least in this particular
case the economic argument was more
persuasive if you look at gender it's
interesting that the economic argument
was particularly persuasive two males it
mattered less to females basically the
the females were inclined to be more
supportive in the first place it took an
economic argument to get the men on
board so interesting gender differences
and this to me is a very important slide
what this shows is that the economic
arguments were particularly persuasive
for independence so
oh the economic argument really seemed a
matter for the independence it mattered
less for Democrats and mattered less for
Republicans that essentially says the
same thing except instead of talking
about independence we're talking about
moderates okay let's turn to another
experiment one limitation of the first
experiment I'm sure has already occurred
to you and that is it was based on
Georgetown University students and let
me be the first to say that Georgetown
University students are exceptional in
many ways so I don't mean to say that
Georgetown University students represent
a microcosm of the United States but I
decided it would be interesting to to
see how people would respond to a
somewhat different newspaper test using
a representative sample and specifically
a random sample of Americans thanks to a
contract with knowledge networks which
did this research for me and allow
people to see the newspaper article
online and respond to it so the question
here for this randomized experiment is
should Congress expand the head start
program increasing enrollment by ten
percent and converting some programs
from half day to full day here I used
six newspaper articles rather than for
the focus was on head start rather than
the nurse Family Partnership Program and
this was an internet survey that was
administered by knowledge networks the
sample size here was a little over a
thousand so we had pretty good sample
size let me just roughly give you a
sense of what the arguments look like
the baseline argument should look
familiar to you from the previous
experiment government spending his way
out of control
taxpayers are already facing serious
burdens as it is we just can't afford it
this time I've introduced an
equal-opportunity argument which is that
every child should have an equal
opportunity to succeed in our society
that was article be so article a simply
provided the baseline argument which is
the taxpayers can't afford it article be
retained the baseline argument and then
added an equal opportunity argument
articles see retained the baseline
argument but substituted an investment
argument for the Equal Opportunity
arguments so here you have a chance to
see whether the economic issue frame
makes a difference article 4 was a
self-indulgent twist on my part I wanted
to see what would happen if if if you
had an economic frame but you had a a
pointy headed wonkish professor using
not just a sound bite but a complex
nuanced fully accurate version of the
same thing I wanted to see if that would
totally destroy the the persuasiveness
of the argument or not then introduced a
science argument the notion here was
that science shows that the early years
are of critical importance to the
development of certain skills and that
therefore we should we should expand the
head start program and finally an
argument that you're familiar with by
now which is the helping hand argument
so the question here was fairly simple
should Congress expand the head start
program and once again the respondents
had the option of using a Likert scale
they could strongly agree strongly
disagree or something in between this
gives you the overall results for the
unweighted and the weighted versions of
the sample and if you focus on the
weighted version what you can see is
that the
most persuasive of these arguments was
once again the economic argument for the
economic issue frame what you can also
see though in fairness is that the
helping hand was doing better with this
national sample than it did with my
Georgetown sample so that was
interesting and to be honest somewhat
unexpected I thought to be honest that
the science string would probably do a
little better and that the helping hand
frame would do a little worse but that's
not the way it turned out for the
population as a whole so with the
analysis I was also able to control for
some other background characteristics to
see if these findings held up and if you
look again at the weighted sample just
for simplicity sake you can see that the
economic the economic issue frame did
matter that it was statistically
significant at an acceptable level but
that it was the only issue frame that
was statistically significant at an
acceptable level when compared to the
baseline so again the conclusion I reach
here is that the economic frame is the
most powerful of these alternative issue
frames although I want to emphasize that
some of these other issue frames are
capable of making a difference and
indeed you see that when you shift to
certain subgroups I'm not going to focus
that much on the subgroup analysis due
to time limitations but let me just pick
one or two to capture the flavor of it
let's see if this is a good one to do
these are both kind of interesting what
you can see from this table which
focuses on education levels is that the
economic issue frame is especially
powerful and especially persuasive for
individuals who have a bachelor's degree
and higher as opposed to individuals who
simply have some college you can also
see that the Equal Opportunity frame is
more persuasive for those who have a
bachelor's degree and higher as opposed
to those who have some college there are
lots of other interesting findings to be
gleaned from these tables but I don't
want to dwell too much on them let me
just summarize them an economic argument
is the strongest pro child argument of
those tried an economic argument is
especially attractive to well-educated
more affluent and moderate voters a
wishy-washy endorsement from an
ambivalent expert dilutes the potency of
the economic argument but not by much
that's good news for those of us who are
wonkish professors an equal opportunity
argument has appealed to moderates and
to Republican voters and to some extent
two males and two senior citizens a
helping hand argument has appealed to
moderates and to parents with young
children and to some extent to young
people a science argument has appealed
to moderates to Republicans and to
parents with young children so those are
some of the findings from the second
randomized experiment but you might ask
well that's all well and good but the
people who make decisions in this
country or the politicians and not the
citizens so how do the politicians react
to these issue frames as one effort to
get at that I interviewed some
congressional staff members who
focus on children's issues that is their
assigned to committees or sub committees
that have children's issues as part of
their formal jurisdiction and I was
careful to include Democrats and
Republicans because I was especially
interested in that difference let me
just show you what some of those results
were here I read some statements to them
some statements that invoked certain
values to see how they reacted to them
to see whether they agreed with them and
I distinguished between the Democrats
and the Republicans the Democrats are in
blue the Republicans are in red and what
you can see from this chart is that the
Democrats typically found any given pro
child issue frame more persuasive than
the Republicans did and indeed even
though I had a really small sample I
think it was a sample of 27
congressional staff members there were
statistically significant differences
for all of these comparisons between the
Democrats and Republicans just because
the differences were so consistent and
so stark the to issue frames that are
most popular with both Democrats and
Republicans are the equal opportunity
issue frame and the investment issue
frame so when you shift your focus from
ordinary citizens to congressional
staffers you see that both the Equal
Opportunity frame and the investment
frame seem to resonate with
congressional staffers who presumably at
least in some rough sense reflect their
bosses thinking although ideally you
would go and try this on the politicians
too and not just on the congressional
staff members so I want to make sure
that there's plenty of time for for
questions but what I'd also like to do
is to touch briefly on a couple of case
studies in my book I've included four
case studies to actually see how issue
frame
blend in to larger political debates
because I would certainly not want to
leave you with the impression that a
good issue frame is likely to carry the
day in any given situation as a
political scientist I know that that's
just not true there are a lot of
political factors that contribute
significantly to any public policy
debate surrounding children their
economic factors that contribute to any
debate when you're in the midst of a
recession when the government is having
trouble paying its bills and when the
government is being scolded for having
over-promised and and overspent in the
past then it is more difficult to make
an argument in support of certain
children's programs if they cost money
in the real world so what happens in the
real world when issue frames collide
with other powerful political social and
economic forces in Connecticut I looked
at that question focusing on juvenile
justice and the question at issue in
Connecticut was whether Connecticut
should increase the age for adult
jurisdiction from 16 to 18 for criminal
offenses in other words if a 17 year old
committed a crime should that 17 year
old be treated as a juvenile or an adult
in Connecticut until very recently a 17
year old was treated as an adult and
some advocates believed that that 16 and
17 year olds ought to be treated as
juveniles and they launched a campaign
there was a coalition that supported the
campaign they got a very impressive
state legislator from New Haven
representative Tony Walker a woman an
african-american woman to lead the
campaign as she did so very effectively
she and her people also
tried to reframe the issues so one
reason why the Connecticut legislature
was very very reluctant to make this
change was that a report produced by the
Connecticut legislative policy shot said
that this would be very costly to
Connecticut taxpayers that it would
ultimately be expensive and initially
that was a sort of conversation stopper
until representative Walker got an
outside organization which turned out to
be the Urban Institute to do a
rudimentary cost-benefit analysis and
they discovered that actually shifting
to a policy where 16 and 17 year olds
would be tried as juveniles rather than
adults would save money for the state of
Connecticut based on the urban
Institute's analysis that economic
evidence turned out to be very crucial
in the ensuing debate and helped to win
over supporters to representative
Walker's cause there was also a
testimony introduced at a legislative
hearing that focused on the adolescent
brain the person who testified was a
psychologist dr. Abigail Baird who was
at Dartmouth at the time and she came to
the legislative hearing and she actually
produced a video presentation for the
assembled state legislators that
featured a shark tank and you see this
very menacing-looking shark swimming
looking very hungry and very malevolent
and she asks adults a question which was
what would it take for me to convince
you to jump into that shark tank the
adults one after another said no way I'm
not going to do it they didn't have to
think twice then she asked the same
question of some adolescents what would
it take for me to convince you to jump
into the shark tank well there you had a
very different response
one person said well would you feed the
shark first and then I would jump in
another adolescent said well would I be
jumping in by myself or with a bunch of
my friends another adolescent said what
would I be wearing would I have some
protective gear and you know which
someone yanked me out if anything
happened in other words they were
seriously entertaining this possibility
they were they were ready to at least
think about jumping into the shark tank
well that video had a big impact on the
state legislators in part because it was
scientific evidence from a respected PhD
in psychology but also because it
resonated with some of their own
personal experiences so this is one of
those wonderful cases where scientific
evidence seemed to support the
politicians existing intuitions so
that's I think a really excellent
example of how issue frames can be used
very constructively and very creatively
to turn a debate around and to
ultimately achieve legislative success
because Connecticut after two years of
consideration and after representative
Walker's very adroit leadership did in
fact change the age from 16 to 18 as she
had proposed now it doesn't always work
out that way so a very different case
study can be found in North Carolina
which is really the tale of two stories
or it's it's it's a tale that changes
over time in 2009 a coalition of various
progressive organizations made a strong
sales pitch to try to retain some some
tax increases and to add some a tax
surcharge to those tax increases
in order to cushion the blow against the
economic recession of 2008 so the way
that the coalition worked the argument
was to say we have a great quality of
life in the state of North Carolina and
they mentioned all the things that North
Carolinians take for granted an
excellent public school system a
wonderful university system terrific
parks and libraries and then they close
by saying all of this could be
jeopardized if the state legislature
fails to approve temporary tax increases
that argument ultimately carried the day
in 2009 and thanks to those temporary
tax increases North Carolina was able to
avoid severe cutbacks in its education
programs in November 2010 however the
Republican Party took control of the
House of Representatives for the first
time since reconstruction you still had
a Democratic governor but the
Republicans now controlled the House and
the Senate the the proponents of
children's programs including education
and higher education and early childhood
education programs brought in their
secret weapon which was former governor
Jim Hunt a very very popular former
governor who actually had created some
of the early childhood programs that
were threatened with severe cutbacks and
he made a very powerful economic
argument in support of retaining those
programs and avoiding severe cutbacks
nevertheless that argument even though
delivered by a spellbinding speaker who
framed the message very cleverly that
argument fell on deaf ears and North
Carolina made dramatic cutbacks in
higher education spending dramatic
cutbacks in K through 12 spending and
even more dramatic
backs in early childhood education
spending so the moral of the story I
think is not that that a good issue
frame always carries the day but that
under the right political and economic
and social circumstances a good issue
frame can make a difference and can lead
towards the establishment of programs
that benefit children or the
strengthening of programs that benefit
children so what can we conclude from
all of this first frames differ in their
ability to galvanize public support for
particular policies second economic
frames which stress that the long-term
benefits of a particular intervention
exceed the short term costs are most
effective should emphasize that economic
frames do not necessarily require the
use of the word economy in your in your
argument or your speech but it's an
economic frame if you're invoking the
idea of investment economic frames are
especially appealing to those voters who
matter the most which is to say well
educated voters wealthy voters and swing
voters on the other hand moralistic
frames can also be effective especially
with certain subgroups some moralistic
frames are more effective than others
I've tried to argue that an equal
opportunity frame is probably the most
effective of the moralistic frames just
as an investment frame is probably the
most effective of the economic frames I
want to acknowledge that there are some
limitations to my analysis I think that
politics dwarfs frames and importance if
you are facing a political tsunami then
you can have the best issue frame that
that a consultant could could come up
with and you're still going to lose the
fight selective media exposure lemon
the public susceptibility to framing you
guys are living in a different world
than the world that I grew up in in the
world that I grew up in if Walter
Cronkite said something on the CBS
Evening News Democrats and Republicans
and independents all got that same
message but now Democrats can pre-select
the media messages they receive and
Republican voters can pre-select the
media messages that they receive and
that means that that it's harder to
reach people through issue framing than
it used to be I also want to acknowledge
that there's more to good arguments than
good issue frames I don't want you to
think for example when you're writing a
policy argument for one of your classes
here at Columbia University that you
simply use a good economic frame that
Professor Walt fogo is going to give you
an A in the course it doesn't work that
way at Columbia University and it
doesn't work that way in the United
States of America on the other hand a
good issue frame is an excellent
beginning and it can help you to
structure a winning argument so I think
that's pretty much what I like to say
thank you for your attention and I'm
welcome to accept any questions while
there's a pause let me say I have copies
of my book if you're interested the
brookings institution has arranged for a
special discount price of twenty dollars
they're also flyers if you want to think
it over and and buy it at at your
leisure and I also have some copies of
some of our articles on universal
preschool if you're interested in that
yes go ahead hi thanks a lot for coming
today um thinking about media exposure
and also just public support around
certain ideas I was wondering if you
could speak to the role of social media
um in issue frame
I think you could probably enlighten me
on that subject as is often typical of
people of my generation I think we are
still pretty startled by the new social
media but in general I think the social
media are are profoundly important and i
guess i would say that because the
social media lend themselves to sound
bites that you can easily imagine a
well-crafted issue frame that is
suitable for dissemination through
twitter that is only you know 10 or or
15 or 20 words in length that can make a
difference and the social media i think
are ideal for disseminating those kinds
of issues reims um I wanted to ask if
you could comment on the frames that you
heard in the state of the union address
and in Rubio's response I definitely
heard an equal-opportunity frame in the
state of the union address and I think
that that was deliberate and I
definitely heard an investment frame in
the state of the union message and I
think that was deliberate i would say
beyond the State of the Union message I
heard an equal-opportunity frame quite
often in the presidential campaign and
not just from President Obama also from
Governor Romney which reflects I think a
relatively high comfort level among
Republicans with that particular frame
with the Rubio speech I was so
distracted by his his water bottle
incident that I didn't focus as much as
I should have on the content of his
speech and I was even reluctant to drink
water here today but notice I have it
right here in front of me so there's no
question that I have to lunge for it and
lose eye contact with you as I lunge
I did however definitely hear an
equal-opportunity frame and I think
senator Rubio has a very compelling
personal story that really accompanies
that that equal opportunity frame so I
think that an equal opportunity frame it
can be very potent a lot of politicians
believe that it is they act as if it is
I think an investment frame can be very
potent and many politicians though not
all of them also use that frame and we
will see if if those frames proved to be
winning frames for President Obama in
the months to come yes I was interested
in the differences between reactions of
african-american populations versus
Caucasian and others you mentioned
gender you mentioned education levels
and you briefly touched on economic
levels but I'd be interested in the race
issue okay let's see if i can find that
yeah what this chart shows based on our
Head Start study is that almost any
issue frame would work for
african-americans in this particular
case that is the overwhelming majority
of African Americans in our sample were
already favorably predisposed towards
head start and so you do not need a
particularly compelling issue frame to
convince them to support the head start
program having said that the economic
frame still looks really good with that
subgroup I you didn't ask about
Hispanics but if you look at the
Hispanic column that's kind of
interesting and what's most interesting
there to me is the power of the helping
hand frame so the helping hand frame
seems to resonate with Hispanic voters
in particular and you know that may have
something to do it may may be cultural
it may have religious roots I don't know
for sure but it's yet another reminder
that members of different sub groups
including racial and ethnic subgroups do
in fact we respond differently to
different issue frames and so if you're
trying to win over members of a
particular subgroup it's good to take
that into account so thanks for your
question yes wanted to go back to your
paradox at the beginning where you
saying that there's this kind of gap
between the sort of amount that we love
children and there's of policies that
support that and I just wonder whether
it is actually true that this kind of
beloved of children what that would mean
in terms of policy mean and like
Elizabeth young brown he's like a
psychotherapist of argues that actually
people in America and another more
liberal societies are quite deeply
ambivalent towards children particular
a other people's children and what that
means in terms of what they'd have to
sacrifice in terms of meeting their
needs so just wondering if you had any
comments on that but whether that was
something that was particularly
something that you could investigate
more about whether actually it is as we
do have this broader love for children
beyond those an iron family yeah it's a
great question I'm simply relying on
public opinion surveys where where
people pretty consistently do indicate
that children are positively constructed
that is they have warm feelings towards
children or they say they have warm
feelings towards children but I've
encountered I've encountered other
sentiments over many years of research
some of my earliest work on children
involved looking at local family day
care homes and local ordinances that
regulate family day care homes and I
basically concluded that the main
purpose of local family day care home
regulations is not to protect children
but to protect grouchy neighbors from
children the essentially what these
ordinances do is to erect certain zoning
barriers and occupancy permit
requirements and electrical inspection
requirements and plumbing inspection
requirements around these tiny little
micro enterprises that are so small that
that you can barely observe them and and
yet we have local governments which make
it very difficult for family day care
homes to provide vital services to
parents with really young children
because though that's where a lot of
parents turn for their their infant and
toddler care so that particular example
would tend to support your your your
concern and your skepticism let me see
if I can find it a chart here
um this is interesting I don't want to
make too much out of this chart but I
guess what I would say is that there are
some Americans who support children's
programs even if they don't have
children or even if they don't have a
young child in their home so the
situation may not be it may not be
entirely bleak now what you'd really
want to see is if you could do it is
what about those households where where
there are no children and they're never
haven't have been children that would be
very interesting to look at so I don't
know I think that that there may well be
a difference between what citizens say
in response to a public opinion survey
and what they actually believe in their
heart of hearts but I I do think that
Americans would like to do better for
their children I don't think that that
advocates or public officials have been
creative enough or persuasive enough in
helping to point to specific public
policies which could benefit children
tremendously that could also win public
support yes all right one more question
I'm interested in your thoughts in the
utility of a human rights framework it's
very closely related to your equal
opportunity frame i was wondering if you
looked at that specifically and i'm
particularly interested because the u.s.
is kind of uncharacteristically and
among world nations not a signatory to
the the rights of the child declaration
yeah i don't know for sure i think a
human rights framework probably plays
better outside the united states than
inside the united states I do think
rights-based arguments in support of
children have
in certain highly delimited policy
domains especially special education and
also child welfare so we are not immune
to rights based arguments in this
country in fact I didn't show you this
chart but one interesting discovery I
made along the way while writing this
book was that that children's advocates
often use economic frames when
discussing education and they often use
economic issue frames when discussing
child health but they are far less
likely to use economic frames when
discussing child welfare when discussing
child welfare they are more likely to
make rights-based arguments or
moralistic arguments and I think that
that those arguments have generally been
efficacious on the other hand many of
those programs are underfunded and and
are not very salient so you could argue
maybe if we had better economic evidence
on the economic consequences of some of
those interventions we would probably
have stronger support from the citizenry
as a whole and from politicians to other
questions or comments
you've made a persuasive case that in
general economic arguments are most
compelling but that for some subgroups
it helps to talk about equal opportunity
and even for some subgroups it talks to
talk about a helping hand and sometimes
bringing science in right is helpful so
have you started yet to look at the
effects of compounding these arguments
so you know you had that wonderful
experiment of I'm going to give you the
economic argument and then I'm going to
add this professor who's not very clear
providing right supposed to be more
helpful information but they actually
just completely undermine the message
what if you take an economic argument
and you add science to it uh-huh so we
know that every dollar we invest is
going to return seven because the
intervention is changing children's
underlying brain mechanisms or their
it's getting under their skin and so ads
you know adds a science element or it
pays off every dollar you invest pays
off seven and it's the right thing to do
you know gosh darn it it's the kind of
country does it undermine the economic
argument to add these others because one
implication of your findings would be
just pile them all on right right just
about put on five different frames and
that way you'll get everybody yeah I'm
glad you asked that question ideally you
do an experiment and you try one
argument at a time and then you try
complementary arguments and then you try
arguments that are not so complementary
and you'd see how they work so I have
two very different reactions to your
implicit proposal first if someone is
testifying on Capitol Hill then why not
use multiple arguments because you have
maybe 10 minutes and you have a rather
diverse group of senators or members of
Congress so when Marian Wright Edelman
testifies on children's issues she
almost always says blah blah blah is the
right thing to do and it's the smart
thing to do so that's a common tactic I
think among advocates
who are testifying before Congress or
before a state legislature or before a
city council on the other hand when
you're dealing with the media you often
have to make some really critical
choices up front you can't do everything
because you're likely to wind up at best
with a sentence fragment in a newspaper
or a very brief sound bite on radio or
television so the strategy for dealing
with the media in my view has to be
starker you have to make some force
choices painful though they might be and
you have to stick with their choice with
your choice because if for example you
use in your conversations with a
reporter if you use an economic argument
and you also use an equal-opportunity
argument and a helping hand or in other
words everything but the kitchen sink
then the reporter is making the choice
if you limit yourself to whichever
whichever frame you think is most
powerful in that particular context then
you're making the choice other questions
yes um could you come back to the gender
difference for the first one where it's
the first one I think okay mm-hmm is
that the one I yes so here like for
females it seems like no positive
argument is even doing better than the
benefit exceeds costs so doesn't mean
you know actually female have some I
don't know what's your understanding for
this result yeah i guess i would say
that i did not find the same phenomenon
for gender when i did the national study
that I found at Georgetown mm-hmm so in
this particular case it is quite clear
that that the females are already Jenner
really inclined to support a nurse
Family Partnership Program and they
don't need an issue frame to convince
them that it's the right thing to do
whereas men do need an issue frame and
specifically an economic issue frame to
convince them that it's the right thing
to do so that was true here let's see if
I can find the corresponding chart for
the National Head Start question oh
that's probably I think I passed it by
um you know here I don't know I guess in
some sense in some sense you reach the
same conclusion that is the issue frames
don't seem to be mattering quite as much
for women in this national sample the
issue frames matter a little more for
men in this national issue sample
although the gender differences are not
that striking here does that help do you
have any intuitions as as to whether a
particular issue frame should matter
more for a manner for women just as kind
of curious what why like is that female
feel like oh if you talk all negative
about this issue I will say no like we
should really support it why others talk
like that I don't know so it's that some
you know maybe just gender difference I
don't know there you know there may very
well be gender differences on some
specific issues so remember I've just
looked at two very specific case studies
in the empirical research here if you
were to look at a number of other
children's issues you might reach
somewhat different conclusions yeah hi
thanks for your talk really appreciate
it there's some research that I'm quite
unfamiliar with about the messenger
Matic mattering and I there was a nice
piece I think it was an op ad in The
Times New York Times the last few months
but i'm not sure if it was there the
post or somewhere else anyways the
question I had was is there any research
that you're aware of on the relative
merits in terms of moving people of the
messenger versus the message it
I think there is some literature on that
and I'm not too familiar with it but I
think the premise of your question is
absolutely correct I'm inclined to
believe that the messenger matters not
just in the obvious sense that some
people are more appealing in delivering
a message but also in in the broader
sense that some organizations have more
credibility with with some groups of
voters than others so to emphasize that
point there's some very interesting
research that's been that was just
published in the american sociological
review that shows that conservatives are
much more skeptical of science than
liberals so what are the implications of
that one implication might be that a
study funded by the National Science
Foundation or a study commissioned by
the National Academy of Sciences will be
more favorably received by Democrats
than by Republicans that the scientific
imprimatur has more cachet with the
Democrats than it does with the
Republicans so that might be one one
possibility the so the messenger can
matter obviously Democrats and
Republicans liberals and conservatives
also have their preferred organizations
there go to organizations that they turn
to when they're looking for evidence
when they're looking for guidance and so
in that sense the messenger may also
matter
okay okay thank you thanks for watching